on this Monday night relief and
Devastation in British Columbia's
interior the battle in the shushwap
intensifies as the scale of Destruction
is slowly assessed we're not done yet
and the most damaged neighborhoods are
still to come the call from small
communities to send help
soaked and shaken this was all water
melted like a lake millions of Americans
clean up after a record Deluge and an
earthquake The Retreat after the shuffle
how the prime minister is looking to
reset and what it could mean for his
future plus charting a new cleaner
course for shipping with old technology
the maiden voyage looking to lower
emissions and costs on the high seas
foreign
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
it is now becoming clear what has burned
to the ground in British Columbia a
province still in a state of emergency
and still in the midst of the worst
Wildfire season on record it is a little
cooler today the winds have died down
but the threat remains evacuation orders
are in place for about 27 000 people
across BC more than 380 fires are
burning 160 of them are out of control
including the McDougall Creek fire near
Kelowna Crews were able to get into West
Kelowna and say at least 50 buildings
are partially or fully destroyed and
that's an early assessment the most
damaged neighborhoods still have to be
inspected further north in the shushwap
region the situation is dire several
communities are being threatened by a
sprawling fire that's 410 square
kilometers in size the fire has already
destroyed multiple homes and people are
trying to help their neighbors in any
way they can Alyssa reports
foreign
when the call for help went out on
social media Mark Taggart wasn't sure
how many would answer it doesn't showed
up early in the morning arriving by boat
by truck and on foot mobilizing in this
parking lot in blind Bay we worked
through all the rules and the csrd and
all the First Responders over there we
are sending food non-perishable from a
non-alert area to a non-alert area some
here bringing water food and fuel with
them others bringing their empty boats
ready to fill them with supplies they've
got perishable food but they don't have
potable water because the water
treatment plants down
they don't have you know snacks and
stuff that they could take when they're
you know out fighting the fires and
stuff like that so that's that's what
was going
the rest of the the North Shore needs
pumps and hoses and stuff like that
Cisco foods saw taggart's post and
offered a full semi-tractor trailer unit
full of water non-paris vegetable foods
and other Essentials the plan was to
offload the truck here and have
volunteers take the items across the
lake to anglemont in a convoy of private
boats we have an amazing support group
so many boats and people delivering
supplies we yeah it's been incredible
but the truck never made it to Blind Bay
20 minutes before it was to pull in here
a setback the truck is in Salmon Arm and
Cisco foods has been told to turn the
truck around and send it back to the
Lake Country organizers were told having
boats on the water however
well-intentioned could hamper
firefighting efforts from above because
aircraft would be unable to draw water
from the lake or make drops in terms of
resupply uh emcr Regional operations
center out of Kamloops is working
closely with local government eocs and
if there were a need for assistance with
that local government doc we would then
provide that support so we would just
encourage concerned residents to get in
touch with their local government and
last word the truck is in Chase where it
will sit until Cisco receives permits to
enter anglemont or a government request
to do so it has been a frustrating day
an emotional day and an exhausting day
and they say they won't stop fighting
until they get the goods where they need
to be
Alyssa Carpenter thanks near Kelowna BC
fire crews are making progress on the
McDougall Creek Fire thanks to calmer
winds and higher humidity those
conditions over the past 48 Hours have
helped push back against the blaze no
more buildings have been destroyed and
rain is in the forecast that's raising
optimism but it's no Comfort to those
whose homes have already burned down
thousands of evacuees are wondering
whether they have anything to go back to
in West Kelowna crews are just getting
into neighborhoods where homes are gone
Richard zusman is there Richard what are
you hearing
as smoke drifts in and out of this
Valley Donna it's the first chance
residents are having to see whether
their home is standing or whether it's
destroyed and there will be more bad
news on the way for some
we just found out yesterday that our
house is gone the hurt break clear
through Tracy Lambert's voice she found
out her West Kelowna property was
destroyed by fire after being able to
spot the rubble through the smoke so we
could see that our property was all in
ashes and then a house beside us our
neighbor their house was saved so it was
like the fire had a mind of its own
after days of not knowing there's now
some clarity West Kelowna fire
announcing Monday 50 structures have
been lost and the count is just
beginning we've done the easy ones
but we're moving into the areas where
the fire burned hottest I described it
as a hurricane
trees pushed over by their Roots this is
the kind of neighborhood that we're in
today so undoubtedly then that number
will grow higher Canada Task Force One
leading the surveying work this
preliminary number does not include any
structures lost in the City of Kelowna
and surrounding areas these homes are
gone these are families who have lost
everything it is
also probably
news that is only going to get worse
residents in some West Kelowna
neighborhoods have been informed no
structures have been lost there with
weather continuing to be good for
fighting fire another good day to Fight
Fire with the exception of our
visibility being impeded by the smoke
locally here in the valley
those firefighters are here from across
BC and around the world and one touching
story Donna one of the firefighters
living here in BC becoming a Canadian
citizen today but instead of doing the
ceremony at home they did it here behind
the fire lines on Zoom back to you that
is dedication Richard zusman thanks
it is another Smoky day across Metro
Vancouver Environment Canada has issued
an air quality advisory it says it will
remain in effect until there is a change
in the weather will meteorologist
Christy Gordon is here to give us a look
at what's forecast Christy
Donna it has been more than a month
since the Okanagan Valley Shoe Shop
region have had any substantial rain and
we really need days of rain to make an
impact on the fire situation that we're
dealing with nonetheless we'll take what
we can get here's a look so I've put the
fires of note on the map that you see
here we are going to see anywhere from 5
to 20 millimeters of rain the problem
with this rainfall is that it's not
going to be widespread we're talking
about more showers or spotty conditions
and it comes with a risk of
thunderstorms so this will begin later
today continue into our Tuesday and then
begin to shift out of the region on
Wednesday but nonetheless we're hoping
for some moisture in those key areas we
had a few Goths out of the southeast
today that helps to push the fires more
towards the north winds are going to be
lighter overnight but then there's
potential for a few gusts once again
tomorrow afternoon thankfully
temperatures are going to stay low and
the relative humidity will stay high we
have widespread thick smoking through
the southern interior today a bit of
improvement across Vancouver Island and
we are going to see that Improvement
shift into Metro Vancouver on Tuesday
but it's not going to last long it looks
like we're going to see a bit of wrap
around smoke pushed back into the Metro
Vancouver region on Wednesday and we
could see smoke all across Southern and
Central portions of the province Donna
back to you Global News senior
meteorologist Christy Gordon thanks in
the Northwest Territories the fire near
Yellowknife is officials say highly
unlikely to reach the outskirts of the
city in the next three days but it will
be weeks before anyone is allowed to
return about 20 000 people were ordered
to leave last week many went to the
small town of bechiko it's about an hour
west of Yellowknife and more than a
six-hour drive from the nearest
community in Alberta as Jeff Semple
reports the scramble to safety has
separated families heightening anger and
anxiety
foreign
crews in the north are moving from
defense to offense but right now we're
looking at going to going towards a
direct attack strategy on the perimeter
of that the fire remains 15 kilometers
from Yellowknife and it was feared it
would hit the city on Saturday but rain
is turning the tide we're also looking
at winds that'll be favorable uh for the
most part we're looking at
um you know moving forward the good news
is sparking some camping in forests
nearby to begin considering a homecoming
I'm bound and determined to get back as
soon as like as soon as I don't think
the fire is going to get get to the town
I think I'm going to try and get back
but whether they'll let us is another
thing
the mayor of Yellowknife says some
residents who left are now trying to
return but unless they're essential
workers the police are stopping them yay
the weather's holding and yay we've got
these fire breaks but it's not yay we
get to come home yet so
um really encouraging people you're safe
where you are and we'll tell you when
it's safe to return waiting anxiously
just down the highway is the small town
of bechiko the closest Community to
Yellowknife where the road is blocked
the community of betchiko was hit with
its own Wildfire just a few weeks ago
take a look at what's left of this home
at that time people here fled down the
road to Yellowknife well now people from
Yellowknife are taking Refuge here in
betchiko Katrina knuckleby is one of
them we seem to be the the poster
children for natural disasters betchiko
is home to the klecho people from The
denne First Nation their MLA says many
of their community members are now
missing it's a nightmare I mean there
was no communication with the engage
leaders Jane will Yellen Armstrong says
in the scramble to follow evacuation
orders some of their elders and homeless
people were rushed onto planes and sent
to cities across western Canada
especially with the language barriers
yeah we're afraid for them and there's
nobody there with them she says even
children in Care Homes were sent away
their parents left with no word on their
whereabouts they wouldn't know where
their children are and then they're
saying this is this feels like a 60
Scoops because they send their children
out Yellow Knife should have done a
better job than dealing with this with
the patient with the homelessness with
with the vulnerable people and it didn't
happen
I asked the mayor of Yellowknife about
those concerns she says the territory
oversaw the evacuation but that no
adults were put on those planes without
their consent though the same can't be
said for children and seniors in Care
Homes the mayor says anyone in the
territory looking for information on a
missing loved one should call 811
Donna all right Jeff Semple in betchiko
Northwest Territories thanks prime
minister Justin Trudeau has taken a shot
at social media giant meta which owns
Facebook and Instagram he says it is
inconceivable it continues to block
local news as dangerous wildfires rage
across much of the country
but right now in an emergency situation
or up-to-date local information is more
important than ever
Facebook's putting corporate profits
ahead of people's safety
ahead of supporting quality local
journalism
the prime minister is leading a retreat
of his cabinet ministers in Prince
Edward Island he says the federal
incident Response Group is meeting to
discuss the wildfires and housing and
affordability are also expected to be a
focus Mackenzie gray is in Charlottetown
tonight
very cool their victories Justin Trudeau
wants to show off hey what's your name
ten dollar A Day daycare a signature
liberal policy but it's increasingly
overshadowed by inflation and housing
concerns leading the prime minister to
make a political pivot there's much more
we need to do on housing and we're
continuing to step up with record
Investments and Partnerships with
Municipal municipalities and provinces
plans for those new Partnerships being
drawn up in Charlottetown as Trudeau's
New Look cabinet meets to strategize on
the political path forward one potential
change capping the number of
international student visas issued to
reduce housing demand the reality is
we've got temporary immigration programs
that were never designed to see such
explosive growth in such a short period
of time
Trudeau's Chief rival conservative
leader Pierre polia won't say what he'll
do with immigration but continued his
Relentless attacks over the cost of
living I think Justin Trudeau would love
Canadians to blame immigrants
for the housing prices that he has
doubled
but immigrants are just following the
rules that he put in place poliov's
message resonating with Canadians is
that conservatives had taken a 10-point
lead over the Liberals every generation
from gen Zed the youngest generation to
say baby boomers the Liberals are losing
them all and it's not just a political
reset but also a personal one for the
Prime Minister speaking for the first
time about a separation from Sophie
Gregor Trudeau first I want to thank
all the people who've reached out over
the past number of weeks with warm
wishes with personal messages with
personal stories that that have been
just wonderful and positive the Liberals
won't be announcing any new policies
here in Charlottetown but they will be
hearing from experts and academics
tomorrow Donna and how to revamp their
political plan
and Mackenzie Justin Trudeau has told
the party he intends to lead the
Liberals into the next election and the
conservatives have launched an expensive
ad campaign to raise the profile of
their leader Pierre pauliev what do we
know about how they are both perceived
by voters right now well frankly Donna
both leaders are not particularly well
liked let's start off with the Prime
Minister 51 percent of Canadians have a
negative view of him according to fresh
data from Abacus that came out today 20
of Canadians do have a favorable view of
him but a lot of the folks who've left
him have been Millennials issues with
housing and affordability there really
have them looking towards Pierre pauliev
and Mr pauliev is viewed as more of a
polarizing candidate either love them or
you don't like them and right now his
negatives are fairly high at 37 percent
I think that ties in with what you were
talking about in your intro about the
idea of a new advertising campaign for
Mr pauliev three million dollars to
conservatives that have spent to try and
soften His Image a little bit but in the
end Donna Canadian politics isn't always
about likability just look at jugmeat
saying in the NDP he's been the most
like Canadian Federal politician for
years but he's still the leader of the
fourth party all right Mackenzie gray in
Charlottetown tonight thanks
massive cleanup efforts underway in the
southwestern U.S coming up flash floods
and an earthquake rattle the nerves of
Millions
in Southern California cleanup is
underway after Hillary hit the first
tropical storm there in over eight
decades rainfall records were broken
across several desert communities
Rescuers had to pull people from swollen
rivers and many roads were flooded at
one point the interstate that runs east
and west of Palm Springs was shut down
Jackson prosco reports on California's
deluge
with incredible power flood waters swept
across some of the driest parts of the
United States
California's death valley received more
than a Year's worth of rain in just a
few hours we've had storms before but
never anything quite this windy and
rainy at the same time the first time in
nearly a century that a tropical storm
made landfall in the region Hillary sent
torrential rain far inland to places
like Las Vegas
in Palm Springs where a local emergency
was declared roads were covered by water
for a Time the entire city was cut off
from the main Interstate all that
started within an hour or two and then
just kept piling up up and the water
keeps coming further back up the Street
in San Diego nearly a dozen people
experiencing homelessness had to be
rescued from an encampment in a normally
dry riverbed our swiftwater rescue teams
are lifeguards and firefighters had to
go out into that River and then things
got worse just as Los Angeles felt
Hillary's power
a 5.1 earthquake shook the city like the
storm the moderate Quake rattled nerves
the Los Angeles Fire Department so far
has reported no damage or injuries in
the city while Hillary is a storm for
the record books there is an unexpected
upside
after a season of exceptional rain and
snow usually parched California is now
free of extreme drought conditions for
the first time in years
Jackson prosco Global News
the American President Joe Biden is
touring the destruction on the Hawaiian
island of Maui the Windswept fires there
were the deadliest in modern American
history
850 people are still missing and more
than 100 people are confirmed dead in
the Lahaina fire Biden is expected to be
greeted with anger and questions over
the government's response
still ahead Saudi Arabia accused of
killing migrants at the border
a troubling report says guards at the
border of Saudi Arabia and Yemen
regularly shoot and kill migrants trying
to enter Saudi Arabia Human Rights Watch
says Saudi border guards have killed
hundreds of migrants including women and
children who attempted to enter the
kingdom along its mountainous border
with Yemen the 73 were page report
contains graphic testimony from migrants
who say guards used explosive weapons
and shot others at close range a
compiled testimony from 38 Ethiopians
who tried to cross the border last year
Saudi authorities deny their guards have
killed any migrants
in Ecuador voters will head back to the
polls in October for a runoff election
no candidate received enough support to
be declared winner after yesterday's
vote left-wing candidate Luisa Gonzalez
won about 33 percent Daniel noboa Son of
a prominent banana businessman was the
surprise second place candidate with 24
percent of the vote the election was
marred by the assassination of an
anti-corruption candidate earlier this
month
sustainable shipping next Wind Wings a
bold plan for cargo ships to sail into
the future
[Music]
cargo ships are an essential part of
keeping the world supplied thousands of
them are operating right now but only
one is making headlines it's set out
from China this morning and what's
notable is not the cargo it's carrying
but how it's powered it's been
retrofitted with massive sales as Mike
Armstrong explains it's intended to help
shipping clean up its Act
it's a little less impressive docked but
on the Open Seas The Vessel the Pixis
ocean opens up its Sails are a bit of a
hearkening back to when cargo moved
around the world before Diesel and
before steam harnessing the power of the
wind the people behind it admit there's
a bit of Back to the Future the pix's
ocean is a is a pilot project that we've
been working on for many years with many
partners the maritime shipping industry
accounts for close to three percent of
global CO2 emissions using wind to add
power could cut that down but what makes
it even more appealing for the industry
is what it could mean for costs normally
vessels we're saving a ton and a half a
day so 30 even 40 percent of fuel
consumption which is a significant step
in the right direction now the Pixis
ocean is five years old the Wind Wings
as they're called were added they were
designed in the UK and built and
installed in China they're 37.5 meters
tall and 10 meters across when at Sea
they pivot and rotate depending on wind
angle and at Port they collapse and move
out of the way to give access to the
ship's Hatches the fact they can be
added to ships may give the technology
the potential to go mainstream certainly
on both carriers and tankers we can see
a lot of proportion of new builds and a
huge number of retrofits in the in the
coming years the shipping industry is
looking at other fuels that are less
polluting than what vessels use now but
so far they've all been prohibitively
expensive which leaves sales as an even
more interesting option
Mike Armstrong Global News
and that is global national for this
Monday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your
candidate is for shoe on Cape Breton
Island Nova Scotia we'd love to see your
Canada please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com and thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]
thank you